hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Danielle and today I'm with my
friend and Maine's health cover model
Carlos takes dear God
Thank You Daniel for having me looking
forward to the Chattanooga nap and I'm
happy that you're here so a couple of
weeks ago we did the men's health
fashion show and colors and I would talk
and we thought hey it's a good idea to
share with you guys the real men's
health cover model diet plan and workout
routine so let's get right into it I
have a dream made mistakes but mistakes
make you strong all right so tell us
share with us your real diet plan okay
so it's a pretty simple straightforward
diaper
I don't see it as a diet I see it as a
lifestyle nutritional plan so what I
mean by that is just you should still be
able to live your life without any
restriction so if you go to apply or you
got it out of the friends you must be
restricted to just eat salad or healthy
you can eat your hand move your inside
with your pudding and have a milkshake
or two it's just about consistency out
of the seven days of the week five days
of the week you should be consistent and
I mean by that is for five days you
should not eat cheat meals but for two
of the seven days you can eat pretty
much what you want you the most for the
thing guys is to to eat protein and call
carbohydrates every single meal that you
have throughout the day and it depends
on what you got it if you want to do is
wait and do some fat obviously you're
going to decrease your carbohydrate
intake so I recommending two or three or
four five meals to take out your
carbohydrates out of the meals but for
muscle gains Korb is your friend yeah so
just just so they know how how much do
you weight what is your length yeah it
suggested AI happen okay it's our way I
know kilograms of pure lean muscle mass
some fat in between places that I've
missed
and then I'm one point nine hundred
ninety C to me
okay so just like guys now I weigh
around 80 kilograms so that's 20
kilograms difference so for me if I
travel sometimes I have to lose weight I
will not be able to work if I am hundred
kilos in another country so for the
fashion models that we need to be a
little bit skinnier so I usually eat a
little bit less carbs so my daily
routine is wake up in the morning and
have my oats with whey protein and then
let me stop with this so my daily meals
are five meals per day so it's breakfast
snack time lunch then my pre-workout
meal and then my post-workout meal which
is an evening's each meal consists of
protein and carbohydrates because
co-op's is your friend yeah and I never
skip a meal if I do struggle to get my
meals in I'll have a protein shake
instead of the meal my diet consists of
200 grams of protein every single meal
and more
250 300 game to call every meal alright
ok so that those snacks that you do in
between what is a if you don't have a
protein shake on hand what are you
useful that so this there's a lot of
alternatives there's so many supplement
brands out there these days
I love years in protein bars I've got a
variety trust boss got low sugar
monologue sugar but great snacks is bolt
on it's healthy snacks just make sure if
there's no peppermint yeah I know the
nicer-looking
but yeah anything both on even nuts just
make sure you get your protein okay just
for you guys that's International Boat
song is what we call here in South
Africa beef church but it's not the same
because both teams makes a lot better
okay so that's a diet plan so the
supplements you mentioned us and so do
you prefer use and supplements I did
prefer use in supplements and the reason
being is the not too expensive for the
quality gate and I've recently launched
a few new products called blue label
which is how I quality protein I don't
know that yes so there's a huge variety
of brands out there that you can use it
depends on what works for you what works
for Daniel one
but for me vice versa so you have to
stick to a brand to see if it works for
you and you need to train and eat
healthy otherwise supplements is a no-go
it's just a addition to your meal plan
so you can't replace your meals with
supplements however you can add to your
meal plan you can add something yeah so
I make sure I use my pre-workout if I
train that's got amino acids in intra
workout very important to keep it like
eating levels by and glucose in your
body with amino acids and then also my
post-workout which is a protein shake
that's that's really most important
supplements of recommend anyone if we
want to go additional you can't even use
BCAA tabs throughout the day
but yah it's you can use distance run
tablets you can use determined powder
anyone Tibet
the three main products must be proven
our intro with
okay I'll add it for you guys in a video
descriptions you can check it out as
well and also what I used throughout the
day is protein water then what happened
yeah as well gave me a gift today yeah
I'm not going to take it out it's great
tasting it's sugar no sugar no carbs
just pure protein and this has got 50
grams of protein so that's a great ways
good it's a great throughout the day
refreshment and even while you work out
your weekend runs it's great time it's
not a sponsored video this is just
really good and a bit of description but
that's about it
now the consistency yes it's it's most
important that my persistence in my head
is that you eat five or six days out of
the seven days a week that you eat
healthy you can't eat that day often the
next thing unhealthy you know rotated
like that but stay consistent then you
will see result hmm what it is is really
a lot more important than working out
exactly it's like you get fit in the gym
but you lose the weight in the kitchen
exactly so let's talk about the workout
routine what is your real work at it
seven days a week 365 you kidding me so
we want to give me it we get back to
consistency systems so that's the most
important part of training and staying
in shape oh yes you'll think it's
technical but in my mind it's simple and
it's work
once again what what's gonna work for me
is something with the data necessary it
depends on your diet as well if you can
try not me and eat like Daniel you're
gonna you're not gonna survive it's
because worth with my training regime
you're gonna have to eat a lot and if
you if you want to gain mass you can
have to train at a intensity that you
you almost you break down your muscles
but you have to both advocated by your
diet so my exercise regime is more or
less seven days a week which consists of
a white training and some cardio
evenings order my weight training and
the mornings of The Mikado of
environment cardio with ab exercises and
then my routine Spencer versus this is
really key to pen-and-paper analysis
very important maybe some not that I
give you know so write this down your
first day what would be upper body like
to lower body day three will be upper
body again then you'll die for will be
your race day on your race day you can
do some cardio you can do some add to
some sprints or you can take the whole
day off I like to go to jump then after
dive for you can stop it they warned
again so it's gonna be again upper body
lower body upper body so your split will
be chaste legs back with chesty good
triceps with packet devices then you
have your race day can you stop it I won
and its shoulders legs and
back again your biceps that's more or
less my routine was actually
confidential but I've given to him who I
know thank you for sharing it works so
each each point group gets more or less
four days of recovery time that's
because the first two days your body
needs to recover and then two days after
that actually starts to grow okay so if
you changes the same body part directly
off each other you need to give your
body a chance to grow and recover okay
so there's a lot of people that argue
about this especially when it comes to
ABS exercised so do you believe you need
to give your body a rest or how do you
do your abs exercises my exercise will
be in the morning I do my cardio you
must see your abs as some muscle group
as well people don't see the ABS as a
mass of food so they think if I got to
the German if I eat healthy they're
gonna have abs but you have to develop
that level you'll see a lot of guys
that's absent they've got a flat stomach
but they do have the light you actually
need to train you have to form the
blocks to come out yeah that's true so
I'll do ABS they said three times four
times a week and that's that's then
divided into three training exercises as
well upper upper abs lower abs and
obliques all right
now perhaps the next I'll be lower HAP's
the next help to beat alright well you
wanted everything what I like about what
you talked about is consistency and
that's something that I said in my
channel a few times as well because
consistency brings results right there
but often our biggest competition is
actually ourselves the biggest problem
we have is ourselves what goes on in our
mind so a lot of people that they they
they jump into it they work out but then
they lose the motivation right so what
keeps you motivated to keep going it's
it's a fairly simple recipe you need to
set the goal that you want to achieve if
you're just gonna try and start a trend
just because of training you're not
going to get motivated yeah it works
with me like that if I don't have a goal
that I'm working towards to do I'm not
gonna wake up 5:00 in the morning just
to work out I do enjoy it but the
mornings that you try I try we need that
goal to wake up yeah makes and for for
me to reach that goal and not disappoint
myself I had to try and everyday too
deep right every day and that's with the
whole working
as well so first of all set the goal yet
if you want to change your body or
change the lifestyle book a photographer
six months a year from now to do the
fitness shoot or do a transformation
shoot and then start from need motivate
yourself to reach that goal the key is
consistency at the moment
the moment you've got that goal and you
start to work for it off way through
you're gonna see results and once you
see results you're going to get addicted
to it and that's all processes gonna
have to follow and by saying you get
addicted to it it just it starts a
change of mind you see results you want
more of it because he's here working if
you're gonna work out two times a week
three times a week for two or three
months you're not going to see results
so what's gonna happen you're going to
be be motivated and that's all key is to
just take on system during your doing a
lot of times as well it's it's so
important to keep the mind and the golf
results will come by itself just keep on
working results will come and once they
leave then you can ever be able to -
thank you so much for sharing and giving
it a little bit of motivation guys let
us know what is gonna be your goal if
you like the video subscribe click the
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos and that's it
[Music]
you